[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and i'm a software engineer
turned content creator making videos
about tech career and life so in order
to get a job in tech or really any job
at all you need to undergo an interview
process in order to see if you're fit
for the role and in the interview for a
software engineer we follow a typical
three-part process where at each stage
the difficulty and the duration gets
longer they test your fundamental coding
skills evaluate your technical strengths
and weaknesses and attempts to determine
if you'd be successful at the job you're
interviewing for so these technical
interviews are no doubt the most intense
and probably most dreaded part of the
interview process which yes in my own
experience the technical interview was
the parts that stressed me out the most
i always carved out time to study and
prep for them even if the work itself
was pretty similar to what i was already
doing at the job i was leaving because i
needed to sharpen my toolset to show my
potential employer what i could do of
course what i studied and what questions
i was asked in the interview changed
over time as i became more senior but my
hope was always to convey what my
technical strengths were to a company
and now that i'm a bit removed from the
industry because i'm not actively
working as a software engineer i'm
starting to see it from a different
perspective because i'm not actively
doing these interviews instead i hear
about them from friends and you all
about how they're going and i realize
that there's a clear message that i'm
starting to hear and it's that technical
interviews are broken now this makes me
stop and think just like whenever i hear
that something is broken maybe it's
because of my past life as a software
engineer i really want to understand why
and how it's broken and in order to
understand that i realized that it gave
birth to a bunch of these questions that
i had about technical interviews like
what are they exactly and what are they
meant to do and how did we even get here
are technical interviews even like the
best way to evaluate someone's skills in
today's world or is it actually kind of
a gatekeeping mechanism for those
entering the industry right now are
there any other alternatives out there
well this month all of those questions
kind of started to boil over so i
decided to finally tackle this topic i
did my research through articles and
papers and interviews some in part
thanks to the sponsor of today's video
formation which trains their fellows to
land jobs at top tech companies i was
able to meet and talk to members of
their team who are really knowledgeable
in this topic to learn more and i'll
tell you more about formation later in
the video so stick around
so i graduated from college in 2014 so a
lot of my technical interview experience
and knowledge was from around that time
when i was looking for my very first job
as a software engineer but of course the
whole field and industry had been around
for a while at that point which meant
that technical interviews were pretty
common then too but you know i never
thought to ask the question until now
how do we get here like where do
technical interviews even come from well
before we had our current industry we
had the dot com era and before that with
semiconductors and before that
well you get the idea so during the
dot-com era when software engineers had
their first meteoric rise to hype
popularity and power
microsoft was arguably the most dominant
player in tech at the time during that
time the tide was changing from these
old well-established companies owning
the industry to a fast-paced uncertain
high-risk but high-reward tech scene and
for microsoft at the time windows was
the most widely used gui operating
system in the world and microsoft office
was taking the world by store so they
needed to figure out a way to hire the
best people in the market the 2003 book
by william poundstone describes how
microsoft hired people in that they
needed to find the most intelligent
resourceful and out-of-the-box thinkers
needed to survive in the
hyper-competitive business world bill
gates the founder was a huge fan of
puzzles and riddles and that became one
of the main parts of the interview
process these are the times by the way
when they would ask questions like how
would you move mount fuji or how many
piano tuners are there out in the world
there are other parts of the interview
of course like technical overviews of
past projects you've worked on or
abstract design questions but by far the
puzzles and riddles questions had the
most buzz they believed that through
asking those questions they could see if
someone would be willing to challenge
assumptions and see things from novel
perspectives which in essence is asking
someone to demonstrate their
problem-solving abilities of course you
don't hear much about those like puzzle
and riddle type questions being asked in
the modern day interview because the
industry's morphed and evolved since the
dot-com era but you see the intentions
of those questions being reflected in
the modern day technical interview and
the need to test someone's abilities in
solving novel problems
now before we go further we need to
define what we mean by technical
interview because it's kind of a loaded
term and that's because there's a lot of
different kinds of technical interviews
out there the most common by far is the
data structures and algorithms interview
they're typically conducted in a 45 to
60 minute session in which an
interviewer guides a candidate through a
coding exercise so in these data
structures and algorithms questions you
might get questions like how do you
check if two strings are anagrams of
each other how is a binary search tree
implemented how is a bubble sort
algorithm implemented other than these
data structures and algorithms
interviews there's a lot of different
kinds of technical interviews too
there's system design interviews live
coding interviews pair programming
interviews take-home projects and
technical behavioral interviews always
test different skills for software
engineers at different companies for
different skills and at differing levels
all these interviews though are roughly
trying to test for a similar thing
you're looking for constructive problem
solving technique you're looking for
fluent coding and effective coding and
in general i would call i would say
that's coding in a way that clearly
communicates the idea or translates the
idea
from the problem-solving phase into code
in a way
that avoids most of the bugs we all
write bugs right so like the expectation
is not that there are zero bugs at the
outset
but it's that you write your code in a
way that shows that you know how to
avoid common mistakes and then of course
at the end you want the code to be
bug-free so there's a there's a testing
component like can you now explore the
code you've written effectively write
the tests fix any bugs that are there
that's daniel tomko a software engineer
who helped craft a lot of facebook's
interview process but by far the most
common technical interview is the data
structures and algorithms interview so
i'm gonna primarily focus on that one
for this video meet adam he's a fourth
year computer science student at the
university of waterloo and he is no
stranger to technical interviews i've
done technical interviews at like dozens
of companies i guess like notable ones
would be like facebook and citadel
shopify square sigma so like mostly on
like the tech company some fintech
company kind of range i decided to
interview adam to understand what the
technical interview process is like for
students who are entering the industry
right now because you know the tech
industry changes at like a rapid speed
and i wanted to get a pulse i just felt
that it was just luck basically that if
you had seen the question on leak code
before
then you would be able to solve it i
knew like to a certain extent that you
could learn a lot of these concepts and
be able to do them but it felt like it
was such a grind to get to that point
that and it was so unrelated to the job
that you would be doing it wasn't a
great metric of my actual skills like i
was confident in my abilities as a
programmer
especially like building apps and stuff
but i wasn't confident in my leak code
abilities and i thought how can that be
like how can it be that i wouldn't do
well in the interview but i think i
would do well on the job i also think
that if you get a bad interviewer it can
feel pretty disheartening if you go in
and you you're supposed to like this
novel question
that doesn't seem like there's any way
you could have figured it out and the
interviewer isn't trying to push you
along and give you pointers and tips
then like you're gonna walk out of that
feeling like you got railroaded and i've
had that happen a couple times where
like afterwards i'm like i don't think
there's anything i could have done
differently now in a nutshell from what
i can understand from adam and hearing
from others who are breaking into tech
these are the reasons why technical
interviews feel so broken they're not a
great way of assessing technical ability
because what they test you on is so
different from what you're actually
going to be doing on the job and that
sometimes if you don't get a great
interviewer or an interview question it
can be really disheartening and cost you
the job i also asked people who were
really well versed with technical
interviews to get an opinion on the
other side and you know what
they said the same thing about them i
think the biggest con it's super obvious
is that it's not similar to day-to-day
work it's not similar in a a number of
ways and there's just this
incredulousness
like comparing like okay if i can
reverse a linked list how does that
inform whether i can change the
background color
on your website there's kind of like a
comical element to like the mismatch
between between the interview process
and then and then the job there's a lot
of like comicalness where people say
that you know the tech industry is the
only industry where the interview is the
hardest part of the job and then after
that it's like way easier that's sophie
novati the ceo of formation she's
conducted thousands of technical
interviews at top tech companies and now
helps people to succeed in them one
you're not typically under such intense
time pressure two you typically have
your standard ide tools that you're used
to even with autocomplete or
the syntax highlighting that you're used
to whatever tool you're used to you're
usually not doing that sometimes you're
in a google doc i've heard some
companies do right so it's just like not
the ideal environment and then there's a
lot of categories of questions
that aren't similar to logic on a
day-to-day level so
why might this be why do we use this as
the standard interview process at
different companies and why does it feel
so broken could companies give better
interview problems that give a sense of
what the work is actually like and could
companies provide better interview
experiences for candidates by doing so
this is starting to get at why technical
interviews feel so broken and i think in
order to understand this deeper we have
to look at it from the company side of
what it takes to craft an entire
interview experience because obviously
when a company is going to hire for a
new person they're going to try to find
the best person for the job and so
there's a whole process for this so in
the interview process they'll think
about things like what question to ask
the candidate to get the best signal
what skills are they looking for in the
candidate for this particular job what
signals interviewers are looking for to
evaluate those skills and how to conduct
the interview in an unbiased and fair
way that judges based on the performance
in the interview and basically what all
these boil down to are two things that
companies really need to figure out how
to evaluate the candidate and what to
ask the candidate
every job at a company comes from what's
called a job wreck or a job requisition
which is when a hiring manager submits a
formal request to create a new position
within the company employee salaries are
typically the largest expense for a
modern day tech company and so hiring
managers need to make a case for why
they want to hire another person they
need to figure out what that person's
going to be doing day to day and what
skills are going to be necessary to make
that person successful maybe it's the
knowledge of a specific technology or
the ability to work fast or being able
to communicate different concepts with a
lot of different people in order to
figure out what they're looking for
companies and teams need to understand
who they are first they need a level of
self-awareness and to be realistic about
who they are in order to find this new
team member concerted effort from
engineers and engineering leadership to
think deeply about what makes people
successful in that company's environment
what do they need to know coming in the
door what can be taught on the job what
skills are important what skills can we
develop versus what skills do we need
kind of coming in and then thinking
about questions that test those skills
and a method for evaluating what's a
poor performance on a particular skill
versus a medium performance versus a
high performance it has to be done
really deliberately and just like the
self-reflection that we do in our
personal life this takes time and energy
typically this type of reflection and
effort is led by the hiring manager but
it really needs everyone on the team
including the engineers in order to
arrive at some sort of consensus about
who they are and what's important to
them some people think it's hr's or
human resources job to do this but it
really has to be the engineers
themselves who are involved in this
since they know best about what's
important to their job doing this work
therefore usually requires several
meetings brainstorm sessions documents
and reviewing and giving feedback to
those documents and decision making and
this is actually one of those places
where interviews can break some
companies and teams just don't have time
to do this kind of work or they don't
prioritize it because it takes time and
energy away from development itself
depending on the company culture
advocating for this type of
non-technical work from engineers can be
really tough because some people view
engineer's primary role to be about
building and designing code personally i
think this is a great use of engineering
time because hiring well means that
you're building stronger teams but even
in my experience product work like
shipping new features and improving
existing ones
always took precedence over other work
like cleaning up tech debt writing
documentation or other intangible work
honestly sometimes it felt like pulling
teeth to try to be able to work on stuff
that didn't have a direct or measurable
impact to the bottom line so i can
totally see how this is barrier number
one for how technical interviews can
feel so broken but here's the thing the
work doesn't stop at just reflecting on
what it takes to be successful at a
company it then needs to be translated
into signals for what to look for in a
candidate to suss out whether they have
those skills or not most of the time the
end product is like a rubric or an
evaluation guide that interviewers use
to fairly and thoroughly assess
someone's skills usually there's several
categories that a candidate is assessed
on using some sort of scale which
ultimately ladders up to whether that
interviewer thinks that the candidate
would be good for the job i think what's
broken about coding interviews
is if you don't have a rubric
that's deeply connected
to what's required for success on the
job then you're gonna end up with a
bunch of different problems number one
you're not gonna get the right people
number two you may end up with a
diversity problem because one one way
like if your rubric is do they solve the
problem your your temptation might
actually be to just ask really hard
questions and if you're asking really
hard questions then you're you're
avoiding false positives right well they
solve this really hard problem so they
must be good right but what then what
you're doing and that might be true but
what you're doing is then you're
selecting for people that either
spent the last year on lead code or have
a cs degree from a top-notch university
and so you're you're eliminating people
that might actually have a lot of
ability and might be great engineers
but maybe don't have the same the same
background instead if you have a really
clear rubric across a bunch of different
signal areas and then you're evaluating
against that very carefully then you can
kind of unbreak the interview to some
degree so let's walk through one of
these rubrics to show you what they look
like medium posted their grading rubric
for engineering interviews in 2016. it's
probably outdated at this point since
it's six years old but i still think
it's a good example so let's go over it
the categories that they graded on in
the technical interview are the ability
to build software the ability to learn
and teach and a values alignment in each
of these categories they define the
signals they're looking for during the
interview for example in the category
for the ability to build software
they're looking for someone who can
demonstrate problem solving abilities
code fluency autonomy has a basic
understanding of computer science
knowledge demonstrates resoluteness in
finding a solution and for senior
positions has strong skills in systems
design
they grade each on a five point scale
strong no
no
mixed yes and strong yes and give
examples of what each look like in each
of these categories
so for example in problem solving a
strong no is when the candidate is
unable to conceive of any solution to
the problem
the candidate is able to describe a
basic or naive approach but is unable to
implement it and a strong yes is when
the candidate clarifies the scope as a
natural first step is able to articulate
multiple approaches and describe the
pros and cons of each makes a sensible
decision based on the constraints of the
interview format and is able to fully
implement the approach without any real
help from the interviewer the candidate
recognizes edge cases and draws
attention to them unprompted then solves
them these rubrics are really helpful in
calibrating interviewers on what a great
interview looks like without a rubric
interviewers might grade candidates on
the wrong thing like things that are not
that important to a company things like
getting the right or wrong answer or
getting to that answer in record speed
accompanies where they have these
rubrics it's usually a core group of
really passionate people who want to
improve the interview experience who
make it but again in order to make one
that fully aligns with the team's goals
and values it really does take time
energy and effort not to mention once
this rubric is made there's a larger
group of interviewers that need to be
trained to interview in a way that
aligns with a rubric it takes a village
to evaluate someone's skills so everyone
gets involved somehow whether that be
hosting technical interviews or
behavioral interviews or doing phone
screens or getting lunch with a
candidate what many companies do is for
interview training it ends up being a
meeting with somebody from hr and that
meeting is about the legal implications
of interviewing so you can't ask about
this again you can't ask about that and
all of that makes sense and all of all
of that is good that's the company
covering their butt and they should
absolutely do that however that's not
interview training that's legal covering
a butt after that what do you do how do
you take this person who now knows the
legal
rules around interviewing how do you
then turn them into somebody who knows
how to evaluate a candidate for that
role and that part is lacking
at most companies that i'm aware of some
companies will just have you like shadow
somebody who may or may not be good at
interviewing themselves most of the
companies that i've worked at don't
actually have like internally published
like rubric and method to to their
interview process it's just sort of this
word of mouth sort of training thing and
it takes time to put that together and
it's engineer time which is expensive so
we've already uncovered a couple of
places where interview processes can
break at a specific company evaluating
what it takes to be successful there and
what skills are necessary for the
company turning it into a thorough
rubric that aligns well with the team in
training engineers to interview well
based on that rubric and looking for the
right signals these are really important
pieces of work that sure a hiring
manager could take on entirely but in
order to create a good process
involvement from engineers is crucial
and unfortunately some leaders or
managers or even engineers don't feel
that this work is as important as
shipping code this bias exists in a lot
of places and each one of those need to
be challenged on their own it takes time
trust and a willingness from that
individual or group to have their biases
challenged in order for change to happen
so you might have noticed that we
haven't even talked about the interview
question itself yet and that's because
only after the reflection and rubric and
training happens can you even begin to
think about what question to ask the
candidate which brings us to the next
part where i think interviews can break
now before we move on i want to say a
big thank you to the sponsor of today's
video formation if you're watching this
video because you're looking to land a
job at a top-tier tech company then
definitely check out formation's
fellowship program sophie is actually
one of the founders of formation and
daniel is part of the team too they have
a really unique program created by staff
level facebook and next door engineers
to create a better way to prep engineers
for the industry once you've applied and
been accepted into the fellowship you'll
get a personalized training plan made to
fill your specific skill gap with direct
mentorship from senior engineers to
getting referrals directly into the top
companies in the industry the program
lasts between three to six months where
they support you unconditionally until
you land your dream role you can do this
part time if you're currently working
and they also have an income share
agreement so you pay zero until you get
hired you can check them out and apply
for free at formation.dev which is also
linked in the description box thank you
again so much information for sponsoring
and now let's get back to the video
so these technical interviews are
designed to be anywhere from 45 to 60
maybe even 90 minutes to allow for
multiple of these sessions to occur
within any given interview process which
let's be real for a second that's not
long assessing someone's technical
abilities in a roughly one hour session
requires a lot of skill i mean imagine
having like in 45 to 90 minute
conversation with someone which at the
end you have to decide whether you want
to spend every day with that person
like i don't think i could even do that
for friends let alone co-workers anyway
because of the length of the interviews
the questions need to end up being
contrived and well scoped which is one
of the cons to the whole technical
interview that both adam and sophie
brought up but here's a thought could
companies give questions based on the
things that actually happen in their day
to day well yeah but then it wouldn't
fit into a roughly one hour session in
my personal experience in order to be a
contributing member of the team there
needs to be an enormous amount of
onboarding before you can even expect to
make an impact there you need to learn
about the company the business the code
base that it uses how the team uses
different technologies certain processes
for development and more in fact my team
at netflix told me that it'll take about
six months to onboard just because
there's so much stuff to learn all these
factors are important because when
you're solving a problem you have to
make sure that you're solving the right
problem so that you can arrive at the
right solution contextual information
can make sure that you do that because
in software the devil's in the details
like as an extreme example imagine that
as part of your interview you need to
build a feature that allows a user to
post a comment in order to build this
you need to know how to install the code
base run the application make changes
commit to the repo make a pull request
and send it to the right reviewer and
then once it gets approved you need to
make sure it gets deployed correctly not
to mention you need to know or build the
api that allows a user to post on a
comment which then you have to know
where in the code base to go to for that
and where to register that new api so
that the clients can see it
you get the idea there's a lot that you
need to know in order to be able to
solve this problem each company and team
does things differently so if this
question was thrown at you during an
interview it'd kind of be a miracle if
you can get it done because being an
engineer is not just about coding i
actually really love how sophie put it
being an engineer is really about
combining programming logic with
business logic you are trying to build a
sign up experience where when you fill
out this information and you click this
button an account gets created and to do
that you're going to write some code to
make that logic happen and so in order
to give candidates a fair chance at
solving a problem within a scoped period
of time you're gonna need to give them a
smaller example so what kinds of
questions can companies give to
candidates granted they need to make
questions that work well no matter who
the candidate is because there's a lot
of variables whether the candidate
started to learn how to code in python
java or javascript where they learned
how to code what tech stacks they worked
in previously what product and services
they worked on before the processes
they've used for building and deploying
code
among many many others as a company how
would you find a question that is
agnostic of all of that so you can find
the right person for the job well it
goes back to the fundamental building
blocks of software engineering data
structures and algorithms what data
structures and algorithms is doing is
it's really removing
all of the fluff i would say of the
business logic layer and really hyper
focusing on the underlying programmatic
logic only so that's why a lot of data
structures you're working with nodes so
like you're working with a linked list
or a binary tree and each node has no
meaning in like your day-to-day
programming that node might be a profile
object that is connected to another
piece of data that has an
intrinsic meaning it's a beautiful thing
that people are coming from way
way more
different varying diverse backgrounds
both in terms of life experience
socioeconomic backgrounds and you know
past work experiences in terms of what
they did
previous to becoming a software engineer
what people have as skills are varying a
lot more in a world where every single
person went through traditional
university and had this like
background then it's pretty fair to be
like okay well we're gonna test you on
that and so now that like people have
more very and there's so many different
like frameworks right so people have
done all kinds of different tech stacks
it's become harder to
to design a process that is perfectly
fair for every single person but one of
the pros is that it is actually quite
equalizing in terms of the
engineering background that you come
from so like no matter what tech stack
you've been on what language is your
primary language right like typically
you're on a platform where you can
choose from like 30 different languages
which one and no matter which web
framework you came from you can do kind
of just the underlying raw coding
exercise without being advantaged or
disadvantaged from which previous
experiences that you've had so in
creating a data structures and
algorithms type question
what exactly does that look like well
ideally companies would give a question
that resembles a real world problem like
for a front-end role maybe it's a tree
traversal question because the page dom
is literally a tree and that's really
applicable for the job but maybe not a
dynamic programming question because
that's not really applicable to most
front-end roles oftentimes
you can make interview questions out of
things you encounter at work sometimes
those data transformation steps make
make good interview questions because
they're super practical coming up with
other interview questions it's a little
bit more difficult and there's
definitely a bit of a challenge to make
sure that they're novel
enough like i have some strong opinions
about what makes good ones
and in general rule number one is they
shouldn't
require
a cognitive leap some sort of a eureka
moment they should be solvable by
bringing
to bear constructive problem-solving
techniques right you should be able to
explore the problem and ask questions
about the problem and then answer those
questions yourself it shouldn't require
like some clever shift of perspective to
like suddenly see the elegant solution
to the problem because then it then it
just becomes a bit of a coin flip
daniel's rule number two
is that ideally the skills required for
a given problem should be in some way
applicable to the job content itself if
it's not connected in some way then why
are they asking this problem what are
they testing if you do well on this
problem or not how does that correlate
to your likelihood of success on the job
so you know asking really difficult
problems actually i think generally is
counterproductive because realistically
most of us as software engineers don't
solve really difficult problems every
day oftentimes we're working on like
connecting systems together and so
companies need to come up with questions
that apply a lot of requirements they
have to be analogous to the job and
media and novel enough to get a good
signal and are fair game to ask based on
that role and this is the other place
where interviews can break it's tough to
come up with a question that works in a
variety of situations and again it takes
time and energy from engineers to do
this of course daniel says that once you
can find a good solution you get a lot
of mileage out of it i've been using the
same handful of coding questions for
many years now i would say there's an
advantage to using the same question
hundreds of times as an individual is
that you become highly calibrated right
you've seen people make every mistake
possible on this problem uh you've seen
people approach it in many different
ways you're aware of what the pitfalls
are right so you can you you end up
getting really good at
at giving hints so once companies figure
out how to evaluate the candidate and
give them a good problem to solve then
these technical interviews start to
become less broken than what they get
credit for and even then the interview
is not going to be perfect because you
can only get so many signals from data
structures and algorithms type questions
like you might miss out on how someone
might work on problems collaboratively
if they can work independently and ship
code if they can communicate technical
topics fluently to a lot of different
people and if they can take feedback on
their code gracefully and so of course
there's other types of technical
interviews to get signals for stuff like
this programming interviews take home
projects live coding interviews
technical behavioral questions because
here's the thing there isn't a one
interview question to solve it all there
isn't a one-size-fits-all interview type
that will unbreak interviews entirely
and that's because every team every code
base and every company is unique i would
really hesitate from
saying there's like a universally good
interview format in which if everyone
did this the problem is solved it's also
an evolving thing right just like any
product development process let's try
something now that we've tried something
the entire industry as a whole is
realizing there are cons to the ways
that we're doing this right and so as an
entire industry we're all honestly
trying to figure out better way better
ways to do that so i don't think there's
a silver bullet and i also think that
the right choice will differ from
company to company how and what code
gets built has real world implications
like what business needs does that
company have or what technical
challenges does that code base present
or what engineers are on the team and
what kind of values do they have when it
comes to writing clean code it would be
disingenuous to create like a
standardized test for whether a software
engineer can really code because
everyone is looking for something
different of course every team and
company has the responsibility to build
out a thoughtful interview process that
works for them and arguably some of them
can really work on their interview
processes but i don't think technical
interviews are entirely broken i think
maybe they're just not perfect and i'm
not sure if they'll ever be perfect
across the industry because it all
depends on the individuals teams and
companies to do what feels right for
them i feel like there's a lot of like
anger towards
the interview process i think it's kind
of counterproductive for people to get
to
there's like places that are going to be
design interview processes that aren't
aligned with your skills and that's not
a good fit for you and that's great you
figure that out by not passing that
process and there's gonna there's a
company that's meant for you
and their interview hopefully is
designed in a way that like aligns with
your skills and so yeah keep an open
mind type of thing yeah thank you all so
much for watching today's video and
thank you so much to sophie daniel and
adam for being a part of it if you'd
like to support my channel to allow me
to continue making these videos in the
future and you'd like some technical
interview advice because i know that
it's hard when you're going through it
then make sure to become a member where
i'll share the advice that daniel and
adam had for anyone going through the
interview right now make sure to
subscribe to my channel to see more
videos like this and i'll see you next
time bye